because basically like like the guys
that are the No No the guys that are the
best most girls can't lock down because
how do they get to be the best they have
a lot of girls
and if they're good and bad like how
many girls you think are calling them
and so like that's why the the
equivalent like that's why I say like
women swipe right five percent of the
time and they hate men because they're
all sleeping with the same one because
it's again 100 of women want 20 of men
and some people argue it's five percent
of men like what person if you want a
guy that's over six foot like what
percent of men do you think are over six
foot fifteen percent